.
OUT FRONT TONIGHT THE BREAKING
NEWS.
NOT READY TO GO IT ALONE,
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR JOE MANCHIN
NOT WILLING TO JUMP ON BOARD
WITH THEM'S, TODAY MENTIONS IS
THE ONE WITH THE POWER HOLDING
BIDEN'S AGENDA IN HIS HANDS.
AND HE IS NOT ON BOARD WITH
DEMOCRATS PASSING THE BILL WITH
NO REPUBLICAN SUPPORT.
LISTEN TO MENTION WHO JUST
SPOKE OUT TO OUR MAN RAJU.
>> WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
BIPARTISAN.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE ON THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS, BECAUSE WE
WERE ABLE TO BRING EVERYTHING
TO FRUITION, WORKING THROUGH A
BIPARTISAN WAY.
REPUBLICANS DIDN'T GET
EVERYTHING THEY WANTED THE LAST
TIME AS YOU RECALL.
BASICALLY WE WILL NOT GET
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THAT DESIRE
ANY URGENCY TO GET SOMETHING
BIG DONE.
>> YOU ARE NOT READY TO GO FOR
DEMOCRATS TO DO THIS ALONE ON
RECONCILIATION RIGHT NOW?
>> I'VE ALWAYS BEEN TO THE
POINT WHERE WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER.
YOU CAN ONLY DO SO MUCH BY
YOURSELF.
THAT IS WHAT --
WE ARE NOT DESIGNED TO WORK
THAT WAY.
THE HOUSE IS.
THE HOUSE IS DESIGNED STRICTLY
FOR WHAT THEY DO.
WHERE THIS REPUBLICANS AND
CONTROL OR DEMOCRATS.
THE SENATE WAS NEVER DESIGNED
THAT WAY.
THE SENATE WAS DESIGNED FOR
OKAY, WE CAN MANEUVER THAT A
LITTLE BIT A MASSAGE IT A
LITTLE BIT AND MAKE IT BETTER.
>> MANCHIN IS COMPLETELY AT
ODDS WITH MANY DEMOCRATS WHO
SAY THEY'RE READY TO ACT ALONE
IF THEY HAVE TO.
THEY DON'T CARE IF THEY DON'T
GET A SINGLE REPUBLICAN ON
BOARD.
MITCH MCCONNELL TODAY SAYS HE
IS NOT SURE THERE WILL BE A
DEAL.
WE ARE REALLY --
THE ONLY WAY DEMOCRATS COULD
ACTUALLY PASS THIS MAJOR
LEGISLATION IS TO DO IT ALONE.
TO PUSH IT THROUGH
RECONCILIATION, WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE ONLY A SIMPLE MAJORITY.
>> IF IT'S NOT SOLD, THE
REPUBLICANS WE CAN DO WITHOUT
THEM.
>> WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
MOVE FORWARD.
>> REPUBLICANS WANT TO COME ON
BOARD SERIOUSLY?
GREAT.
IF NOT WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
ALONE.
>> I THINK WE ARE GETTING
PRETTY CLOSE TO A FISH OR CUT
BAIT MOMENT.
>> MANCHIN JUST NOT THERE.
HE IS SAYING IT'S GOTTA BE
BIPARTISAN.
RIGHT NOW, THAT IS WHAT POWER
LOOKS LIKE.
THE RESPONSE, BIDEN HAS OFFERED
TO SLICE THE PRICE TAG OF THE
BILL BY NEARLY HALF FROM 1.7
TRILLION TO ONE TRILLION
DOLLARS.
IT WAS IN REPUBLICANS, IT WAS
MANCHIN.
HE MADE IT CLEAR HE IS AGAINST
PAYING FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL BY HIKING THE CORPORATE
TAX RATE BY 28% AS DEMOCRATS
WANT.
THIS IS WITH POWER LOOKS LIKE,
BECAUSE TODAY CNN IS LEARNING
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS NOW
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO PAY FOR
HIS PLAN WITHOUT RAISING
CORPORATE TAXES.
THIS IS POWER.
THIS POWER GOES BEYOND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BIDEN NEEDS MANCHIN ON BOARD
FOR HIS OTHER PRIORITIES
INCLUDING A MASSIVE BILL ON
VOTING RIGHTS.
THAT WILL REQUIRE MANSION TO GO
ALONG WITH ELIMINATING THE
FILIBUSTER.
SOMETHING THAT HE HAS BEEN
CLEAR ON.
HE JUST TOLD OUR MINUTE RAJU HE
IS UNWILLING TO BEND ON THAT.
>> YOU'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT
YOUR DESIRE FOR THE SENATE.
>> NO, I AM STILL VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT.
>> COULD YOU JUST SAY --
TAKE IT OFF THE TABLE AND SAY
YOU WILL NEVER REDUCE THE 60
VOTE THRESHOLD ON THE
FILIBUSTER?
>> LET ME JUST TELL YOU ONE
THING, WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
SENATE WORK THE WAY IT WAS
INTENDED TO WORK.
I'M TOTALLY COMMITTED TO THAT.
I'VE OFTEN CAUTION TO THE WIND,
I'VE NEVER DESIRE TO DO THAT.
I'VE LISTENED TO EVERYBODY'S
POINT OF VIEW.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
COUNTRY HAS GOT TO UNITE.
WE CANNOT DIVIDE IT.
>> NOT GONNA GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER?
A NO GO?
ON WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE NOW IN
COURSE WANTING TO HAPPEN?
IT CANNOT HAPPEN IF HE IS NOT
ON BOARD WITH IT.
ALL OF IT LEADING BIDEN EARLIER
THIS WEEK IN FRUSTRATION
DISSING GOAL MANCHIN OUT WITH
ANOTHER DEMOCRATIC SENATOR,
KIRSTEN CINEMA.
>> I HEAR ALL THE SPOKESMAN ON
TV SAY WHY DOESN'T BIDEN GET
THIS DONE.
BECAUSE BIDEN ONLY HAS THE
MAJORITY OF EFFECTIVELY 4 VOTES
IN THE HOUSE AND A TIE IN THE
SENATE.
WITH 2 MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
WHO VOTE MORE BY REPUBLICAN --
>> THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY
ACCURATE.
BIDEN IS WRONG ABOUT THAT FINAL
POINT.
THERE MANSION AND SINEMA HAVE
VOTED WITH DEMOCRATS MOST OF
THE TIME, BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS.
YOU'VE GOT THE POWER.
YOU HEARD MENTIONS COMMENT
TONIGHT.
FRUSTRATED A LOT OF DEMOCRATS.
MANU RAJU IS OUT FRONT TONIGHT
AND MORGANTOWN, WEST VIRGINIA,
WHERE YOU JUST SAW HIM SPEAKING
TO SENATOR MANCHIN.
JEFF ZELENY IS OUT FRONT LIVE.
LET ME START WITH YOU, MANU.
YOU SPOKE TO SENATOR MANCHIN.
ONE MORE DID HE TELL YOU?
>> HE'S BEEN MAKING IT VERY
CLEAR THAT HE IS NOT READY TO
BUCK REPUBLICANS IN THE 50/50
SENATE.
THAT IS SO SIGNIFICANT, BECAUSE
GETTING LEGISLATION THROUGH
WILL REQUIRE EITHER JOE MANCHIN
CHANGING HIS POSITION, TRYING
TO GET AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE DONE ALONG STRAIGHT
PARTY LINES, AND I THINK THEY
COULD DO PRESUMABLY THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS THAT ALLOWS THEM
TO AVOID A REPUBLICAN LED
FILIBUSTER, HE IS NOT READY TO
DO THAT.
HE SAYS TALKS NEED TO BE
CONTINUED, AND THEY'VE BEEN
GOING ON FOR MONTHS.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS SAY LET'S
GIVE UP.
HE IS ALSO NOT READY TO ABANDON
THE FILIBUSTER TO GET A MAJOR
VOTING LEGISLATION THROUGH THE
SENATE.
HE APPROACHES THE DEMOCRATIC
PLAN, BUT HE IS ALSO WORKING ON
A NARROWER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AIMED TO BOLSTER VOTING RIGHTS
AND ACCESS.
THAT EVEN IF 10 REPUBLICANS
DON'T AGREE WITH THAT HE IS NOT
ON BOARD WITH THE IDEA OF
CHANGING THE FILIBUSTER RULES
TO ALLOW THAT VOTING
LEGISLATION TO MOVE FORWARD,
BUT HE MADE CLEAR THAT HE IS --
HE REALLY WANTS TO MAKE 2 SIDES
WORK TOGETHER.
THE QUESTION IS WILL HE CHANGE
HIS MIND?
HE'S MAKING IT CLEAR HE IS NOT.
>> HE'S MAKING IT VERY CLEAR IN
THE INTERVIEW.
>> MITCH MCCONNELL WANTS TO
WORK WITH.
YOU LAST YEAR HE BLOCKED THE
COMMISSION AND HE COULD HAVE --
YOU'RE SAYING THAT HE WANTS TO
WORK WITH YOU?
>> I'M NOT SAYING THAT.
I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED.
I THINK IT WAS WRONG, BUT HE
DID.
I'VE SAID THAT.
HE KNOWS I FEEL BAD ABOUT THAT.
THEY LOOK AT IT IS A POLITICAL
--
I LOOK AT IT AS OUR COUNTRY
COMING BACK TOGETHER.
IT WAS TOTALLY BIPARTISAN.
IT WAS WHAT THEY ASKED FOR.
HE WAS VERY --
CHRISTENED WAS VERY GRACIOUS IN
WHICH SHE OFFERED, MAKING A
TOTALLY BIPARTISANSHIP.
SCHUMER SAID OK I'LL DO THE
SAME.
THEY WERE ABLE TO COME TO
DISAGREEMENT.
EVERYTHING WAS DONE IN A MOST
BIPARTISAN WAY.
--
ONE PERSON BLOCKED IT ON THAT
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE HAVE
7 PEOPLE, WE NEED 3 MORE VOTES,
LET'S GIVE IT ANOTHER SHOT.
>> SO YOU COULD SAY YOU WILL
NEVER PRODUCE A 60 VOTE
THRESHOLD?
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
PLACE WORK.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THIS PLACE
WORK.
YOU >> ARE NOT TAKING IT OFF
THE TABLE?
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
PLACE.
WERE >> YOU ARE NOT REDUCING
THE 60 VOTE THRESHOLD OFF THE
THRESHOLD?
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
PLACE WORK, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE I CAN TELL YOU.
YOU CANNOT MAKE IT WORK UNLESS
THE MINORITY HAS AND PUT.
YOU CANNOT DISREGARD A PERSON
THAT IS NOT IN THE MAJORITY.
THE SENATE WAS NEVER DESIGNED
THAT WAY.
I HAVE SAID THIS, IF YOU WANT
TO WORK IN THE SENATE, WHY DO
WE HAVE 2 SENATORS FOR EVERY
STATE?
SMALL AND LARGE?
WHAT ARE OUR FOUNDING FATHERS
THINKING OF?
THE STATE BACK THEN OF DELAWARE,
RHODE ISLAND WAS A VERY SMALL
STATE COMPARED TO NEW YORK AND
VIRGINIA?
HE WANTED THAT INPUT.
WE WANT THAT INPUT.
>> YOU GOTTA GO AND ONE 2ND,
BUT ALSO JUST IN THE CENTER SO
MANY ISSUES, EVEN WASHINGTON,
ONE OF THE ISSUES AS YOU ARE
WORKING ON TRYING TO GET A
VOTING RIGHTS BILL PASSED.
LET ME JUST FINISH THE
QUESTION.
THERE IS NO SIGN THAT THERE IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE 60 VOTES
TO GET THAT DONE.
SOME OF YOUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES SAY JOE MANCHIN
SHOULD AGREE FOR AN EXEMPTION
ALLOWING VOTING RIGHTS TO BE
PASSED ON A SIMPLE MAJORITY.
WE SHOULD BE OPEN TO THAT?
>> HOW WELL DID THE 2013
NUCLEAR OPTION WORK WHEN IN
2017 IT CAME BACK AND TOOK IT
OFF THE SUPREME COURT?
THAT GOES AROUND COMES AROUND.
LET'S WORK TOGETHER.
LET'S FIND A PATHWAY FORWARD.
>> YOU WOULD NOT DO THAT
EXEMPTION?
>> LET'S FIND A PATHWAY
FORWARD.
>> JOE BIDEN SAID YOU'VE MORE
WITH REPUBLICANS THAN
DEMOCRATS.
>> I THINK THAT'S OUT OF
CONTEXT.
THAT'S TOTALLY OUT OF CONTENT.
I SPOKE WITH THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> SO THAT KEY POINT THEY'RE
SAYING THAT WOULD COMES AROUND
GOES AROUND.
THAT IS THE WARNING THAT HE HAS
BEEN GIVING SAYING THAT IF WE
DO CHANGE THE FILIBUSTER RULES
ULTIMATELY REPUBLICANS WILL BE
BACK IN THE MAJORITY AND THEY
WILL DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
WHICH IS WHY HE IS HOLDING --
DESPITE RELENTLESS PRESSURE BUT
THAT MEANS JOE BIDEN'S AGENDA
HINGES ON THE SUPPORT OF ONE
MAN.
ONE THING WORK WITH THE
REPUBLICANS.
>> IT IS INCREDIBLE.
INCREDIBLE TO HEAR HIM STAND UP
AND NOT BACKING DOWN THERE IN
HIS CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
MANU, INCREDIBLE.
GETTING THE PRICE TAG CUT IN
HALF TO TRY TO GET HIM ON
BOARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MANU.
I WANT TO GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH JEFF ZELENY.
>> JEFF, SENATOR MANCHIN SPEAKS
AND THE WHITE HOUSE LISTENS.
HOW CLOSELY ARE THEY WATCHING?
SENATOR MANCHIN'S EVERY WORD
RIGHT NOW?
>> THEY ARE THERE WATCHING HIM
VERY CLOSELY, BUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN, PERHAPS THE CLOSEST OF
ALL.
ONE THING IS KEY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULD LIKELY
HAVE NOT BEEN SURPRISED BY
ANYTHING THAT WE JUST HEARD
FROM SENATOR MANCHIN, BECAUSE
HE KNOWS THAT THIS IS PART OF
THE PROCESS, AND THEY HAVE TO
RUN OUT THE FULL TAPE HERE.
THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY TRY TO
GET A BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT.
THIS IS NOT FOR SHOW, THIS IS
NOT POLITICAL THEATER.
THIS IS NOT SOME RUNNING OFF
THE CLOCK.
THIS IS KEY TO TRY TO GET THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL RIGHT NOW
THAT IS ON THE TABLE PAST.
THAT IS WHY --
THE REPUBLICAN SENATOR FROM
WEST VIRGINIA IS COMING BACK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE TO HAVE A FILM
CALM TOMORROW WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND WE WILL SEE HOW
SERIOUS THEY ARE NEGOTIATING,
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
NEED TO PLAY OUT.
NOW WE HEARD SENATOR MANCHIN
LEAVE THE POSSIBILITY OPEN FOR
WHAT HAPPENS IF NEGOTIATIONS
COMPLETELY FAIL.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
HE DOES GENERALLY VOTE WITH
THIS WHITE HOUSE.
BUT THE REALITY IS DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS AND DEMOCRATS ACROSS
WASHINGTON CAN BE ANGRY.
THEY COULD BE FUMING, IT COULD
BE FURIOUS, BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT IS WHO THEY HAVE.
WITHOUT HIM THEY WOULD HAVE 49
SENATORS.
THIS WOULD BE AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION.
SO THEY SHOULD HAVE WON MORE
SEATS AND OTHER RACES LAST YEAR
IF THEY WANTED TO AVOID THIS
PROBLEM, BUT THIS IS THE
SCENARIO.
BUT THE RELATIONSHIP I AM TOLD
BY TALKING TO PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE BETWEEN PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND JOE MANCHIN, THE 2
CHOSE AS WE CALL THEM A LOT, IS
CRITICAL HERE GOING FORWARD, WE
DO NOT KNOW THAT IS THESE
BIPARTISAN'S NEGOTIATIONS
FAILED THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILL USE THAT GOOD RELATIONSHIP
TO TRY TO GET THE AGENDA TRUE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER,
THIS SENATOR MANCHIN VOTES WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN VIRTUALLY ALL
THE TIME.
WE WILL SEE IF HE DOES COMING